Roberts at II know the senior historian
at the National World War two Museum in
New Orleans is here in Norman II Bob
good morning thanks for being here again
exactly the invasion began on Omaha
Beach which is just beyond the trees we
see behind us here in the cemetery what
was at stake you know the simple answer
to that is everything was at stake World
War two had been raging now for five
years and it was time to bring it to an
end every month it extended it was more
death more mass murder starvation the
situation couldn't have been more dire
certainly the Germans were taking their
lumps but it was time to end the Hitler
problem once and for all and that's what
was at stake in the d-day invasion this
invasion had been planned for literally
years could it fail it's entirely
possible the d-day invasion might have
failed anytime you have anything this
complex air land sea 150,000 troops
thousands of tanks and planes I can
think of a hundred ways the d-day
invasion could have failed a sudden
storm could have wrecked the d-day
invasion and they happen all the time
here in the channel and there was this
really a one-shot deal would they been
able to pull this off again because of
the size and scope and complexity if it
doesn't work it's not like you have a
second shot in the chamber Winston
Churchill said this vast operation is
undoubtedly the most complicated and
difficult that has ever taken place I
would back that up 100% and I think it's
true even to the present day even here
in 20 will we ever see anything like it
again hard to imagine you learn never to
say never in the historical business but
it's hard to imagine anything of this
size and scope when you talk about the
planning there was even actually a a
fake operation that they constructed to
distract the Germans correct so we put
George Patton in charge of a phantom
Army Group first US Army Group we fake
radio messages inflatable tanks that
look like real tanks from aerial
reconnaissance
we were pulling a leaving nothing
untried you know we had to have every
advantage and a little bit of deception
as always a good when you consider the
the volume of military personnel and
equipment that was at stake here because
you had 150,000 men you had thousands of
planes and ships how was that
coordinated it was coordinated in a good
old-fashioned style of pieces of papers
and and sharpened pencils this is the
heart of analog
technology of course nothing is digital
there's no GPS to tell your troops where
they're going so this is old-school it
is old-school and the veterans that
we've seen here today they were part of
that they understood how epic it was at
the time and and remains what do you
what is their legacy at this point they
are there are so few of them left their
memory once they're gone memory becomes
history it's no longer a living
breathing thing it's words on a piece of
paper I write books myself but you have
to have that tie with the actual person
who fought you know at the national
World War two museum we've done 10,000
oral histories to make sure that the
memories of these veterans are always
going to live on yeah and as we can see
them for those who were here today this
this ceremony meant an enormous amount
to them
Robert Santino thank you very much for
being with us thanks Evan